My name is Patricia Jones Byrd.
And I am the proud teacher
of fourth grade reading language arts
at Plummer Elementary school in Cedar hill, Texas.
I am 66 years old.
In spite of my age,
I suit up every day and I do the work with fidelity
and with vibrancy.
I have been an educator for 38 years.
13 of those years have been at the classroom teacher level.
In addition to that, I have served
as an assistant principal, then as a principal
and I was superintendent
at that charter school system until 2016
and I decided to retire.
My husband and I have been married for 43 years
and he and I have a daughter.
Throughout my career
my husband has been my greatest champion.
When my husband was diagnosed with cancer in 2016,
I knew that I had to return to work
to help fund the cost of his cancer care and his treatments.
It wasn't rocket science that I provide the same level
of support for him in his time of need
that he has provided for me.
And I ended up at Plummer and I have no regrets whatsoever.
Lawrence is doing well.
The cost of the medication
continues to challenge our finances
but I went back for the right reason.
What I enjoyed most about teaching,
the reason that I'm here is to influence the trajectory
of the lives of scholars.
(upbeat edgy music)
Hi everybody.
Hi.
How are you?
Good. How are you?
I'm so happy to be here with you guys.
We've been prepping for this for weeks
and just so excited to celebrate Patricia.
Yes.
Thank you.
And where is Lauren, Patricia's daughter?
I'm Lauren.
Hi, Lauren.
So your mom has been a teacher longer
than you've been alive.
Yes, she has.
And so it kind of reminds me of that song
of "You Are My Sunshine."
Like she's everybody's sunshine.
It doesn't matter if you're the custodian.
It doesn't matter if you're the principal.
It doesn't matter who you are, everybody matters.
And she's taught that to so many people.
Where do you think she learned it from?
I think she learned it from her family.
She had 13 brothers and sisters
and so she appreciates every little thing
and she wants kids that are without
to feel like they matter
and that they can succeed and they will
as long as you just put some hard work into it.
So that's my dad.
Hi.
What was it like in your family,
going through something like that?
Ugh, I'm so sorry.
How scary, how did she manage to teach
and take care of you at the same time?
Once you know Pat, she's driven.
And once she commits to something,
she's gonna finish it through.
And who here has a nephew that studied with her? Yes.
When I chose to bring my nephew to live with me,
he was in a situation where he was
in a high crime ridden neighborhood.
He had already been held back a grade.
Patricia Byrd is a five foot giant.
Her intentions, her focus, her compassion
and sincere care for people is immeasurable.
When my nephew left that grade with her,
he spoke a new tune, sang a new song
and his aspirations are higher than I could imagine.
So I'm indebted to her.
We just so admire Patricia and everything she's doing.
Now, I guess we're gonna surprise her.
(crowd laughing)
Yes, she has no idea.
She has no idea.
I love that.
(everybody laughing)
I'm also gonna go get on the PA system.
Oh wow.
What do you guys suggest I say on the PA system?
What would make Patricia go, "What's happening?"
Meet in the front office right away, please.
Right away. Okay, urgency.
She follows instructions
very well, like.
And should I call her
Mrs. Byrd or Patricia Byrd?
Mrs. Byrd.
All right, I love it! Let's go surprise her!
Perfect.
All right, everybody.
(all cheering)
(upbeat edgy music)
And so basically the author used all cats.
Notice that, all cats.
Mrs. Byrd, you are needed in the front office right away.
Not sure what that's all about.
I'll be back as quickly as I can, okay?
(suspicious music)
(Patricia yelling)
(inspirational music)